frédéric mercier bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté de témoigner ce matin en direct
dans la matinale de rtl france alors
votre maire est donc décédé il ya à peu
près trois semaines du coc vide à
l'hôpital pourtant ce n'était pas pour
cela qu'elle était qu elle avait été
admise non retour à tous les noms
n'étaient pas admises pour ça le moment
était rentré pour une chute tout simple
sur soi l'île de groix parce qu'ils
vivaient sur l'île de groix et voilà
donc qui s'était mis à l'isolément parce
qu'il a été bon pas tout jeune non plus
80 82 ans et sur une malheureuse chute
là-bas dans sa cuisine mal de dos bien
sûr suite à la chute elle est tombé sur
les fesses de tout son poids et elle me
disait au téléphone j'ai mal au dos qui
va te faire contrôler va te faire
contrôler et donc qu'ils ont pris le bac
le bateau pour aller faire contrôler à
l'hôpital du scorff un de chez nous à
lorient et s'est avéré bon sur un
scanner que le elle avait une petite
fissure sur une vertèbre fissurée
vertèbres et ils ont détecté également
une petite inflammation ou pourront ma
mère fumait c'est vrai depuis des années
vive et sans médicaments sans oxygène
sourire puisque elles étaient dites moi
au grand air à groix sur son sur son
caillou comme il le comme elle le disait
et voilà donc elle a été hospitalisée au
service de pneumologie pour traiter par
augmente ainsi s'il y voit là le poumon
en attendant qu'un corps c'est de lui
soit fait sur mesure pour sa vertèbre
certes m et voilà l attraper le le coc
vie pendant une sur l'hospitalisation
d'une semaine et demie
malheureusement via eu un cluster
cluster à l'hôpital du scorff
dans ce même service la stress généré ce
cluster et bien avérée frédéric mercier
elle a bien travaillé faïd était il est
avéré c'est sûr puisqu'il a été publié
sur le sol et les médias chez nous qui
est ouest france p g a été publié
maintenant est sorti de son
hospitalisation pour la partie tôt et
traiter en même temps un petit peu
d'oxygène et puis dodo 10 d'augmentation
6 7 jours de ce qui nous a été dit est
elle sortie le 26 et ça s'est dégradé 29
donc trois jours
ce qu'on sait ce que l'on entend sur
l'incubation au niveau de cette maladie
là il n'y a pas brillé pas mystère et ça
a été reconnu en partie par les médecins
qu'ils s'en soient occupés donc voilà
voilà notre histoire
comment comment vous réagissez à ce
moment là justement nous aurait agi que
si vous voulez cette histoire là n'était
pas écrite comme ça ma mère de 82 ans a
eu une semaine d'arrêt sur sur une
rythme en une un petit pmu sur une sur
sur une sur une angine donc n'ai jamais
eu de médicaments sans voilà on n'a
jamais été hospitalisé mais était en
super forme
elles rendent pour une malheureuse chute
il très comparable quand on vous a dit
qu'elle avait le comique
comment est ce que vous avez réagi vous
et vos proches d'un mois déjà nous on ne
le dit pas assez que nous on s'en
aperçoit bien sûr que deux jours ou
trois jours après son eau sont sur la
sortie de l'hôpital elle sait elle se
dégrade elle était fatiguée elle me
parlait au téléphone en posant le
téléphone et puis au fur et à mesure du
temps nous on est sur lorient
lorient est mon frère parce qu'on est
j'ai un frère aussi sûr qu'elles
invoquent on est à distance on faisait
part du téléphone n'en voyais bien qu'à
la discussion ça se dégrader et puis
donc avait été testée positive le deux
voyelles est sorti le 26 elle est
rentrée sur groix le 28 puisque le 27
qu'ils ont fait un réglage de corse et
il ne me le 3 le 3l été positif dont le
niveau là il n'y a pas de mystère c'est
à faire là qui l'emporté
il l'emporté que vous dise le personnel
hospitalier à ce moment là quand
effectivement on se rend compte que
votre mère est positive au co vide elle
personnels hospitaliers eph embêté parce
que elle avait été sujet fait attention
elle avait été hospitalisée sur sa
première et hospitalisations pour
l'histoire du dos plus en parallèle je
vous dis le dans ce même service de
pneumologie et ils l'ont remis en
oenologie quand elle était après le
transféré par hélicoptère est mis au
départ choix en réanimation et après
monter le lendemain dans ce même service
de pneumologie donc l'élève et les
soignants qui l'avait vue de trois
semaines auparavant
l'onr vu qu'on était il était désolé
maintenant on sait que c'est pas le sait
pas le problème des soignants en eux
mêmes c'est le souci qu'il ya c'est que
nous on a rencontré la direction de
l'hôpital qui a accepté de nous
rencontrer et on a en a pris
chose où il n'y a pas si vous voulez
d'obligations de tester les soignants
dans ses services la pneumologie ou
néanmoins comment dirais-je de
réanimation c'est sur le bon vouloir des
soignants c'est sur le dire des
soignants s'ils ont été en contact pas
contactez moi je pensais qu'ils étaient
dans ses services la tester tous les
deux jours pour éviter justement qui
ramène la co vide dans leurs propres
services déjà pour leur sécurité a eu
déjà pour la sécurité des patients mais
non rien n'est fait rien n'est fait nous
ont avoué nous ont avoué que c'est au
bon vouloir c'est vous dire si les gens
sont absents plus de 4 5 jours
il est est cécile sont asymptomatiques
qui ne le savent pas sylvain voilà c'est
donc vous pouvez ramener tout ce que
vous voulez dans les services
aujourd'hui frédéric mercier vous
témoigner aujourd'hui justement parce
que les cas se multiplient on le voit
bien vous allez porter plainte
on ne s'est pas encore porté plainte
nous on n'a pas nous c'est pas le
financier qu'on cherche avec le frangin
c'est surtout mettre en garde donc dans
le service où où es tu es moment déjà
des choses que l'on a vu on a constaté
au niveau sanitaire
mon père mon père à nos mots mon frère
travaille dans l' hyper hyper propres
autres propreté et donc c'est pas perçu
de deux choses qui sont scandaleuses
maintenant on essaye de l'on veut
essayer que les prochaines personnes qui
rentreront ne ressortent pas que maman
est ressorti les quais devant quoi donc
la maman si vous voulez voilà c'est plus
sept minutes là c'est plus après on
verra le speg l'aspect le speg tribunal
enfin tous ces trucs là où on n'est pas
encore rendu là mais on et voilà nous
mon père mon père bien sûr a été testé
positif lui dise ah mais varié anglaise
avait parié en anglais puisque ça a été
notifié par les laboratoires aient été
testés positifs mon père 81 2 ans 58 ans
le mariage sa vie s'est arrêtée
voilà donc pour sa femme qui rentrait
pour un contrôle de dos picard sur pied
avec cette affaire merci frédéric monier
d'avoir accepté de témoigner dans la
matinale de rtl france ce matin